(slow orchestral music)
(laughter)
- [Narrator] I was in a
show which was the most
popular show ever in
the former Yugoslavia.
(laughter)
Imagine we had over two and
a half million audience live.
(laughter)
Being popular like that you can
not even walk on the street.
My name is Jasmin Geljo,
and I'm an actor.
I came as a refugee in 1993
to escape
the war over there.
I love my profession.
I like to make people happy.
When I came to Canada
I realized I didn't have
the tools to be an actor
cause I didn't speak English.
You have to survive
somehow, you have to work.
I was working so many
different type of job.
When I was a salesperson
like knocking door to door
trying to sell perfumes,
I was recognized as an actor
by people from former Yugoslavia,
but I didn't want to speak my own language
because I was so ashamed for them
to see me in that kind of position.
Being somebody and dropping really
to become nobody.
(piano music)
I learned English by
listening to other people.
And started auditioning, I found agent and
small part by small part, I, you know,
I start working my profession again.
Two thousand dollars.
- Oh.
- Best I can do.
Being an actor with an accent,
I always play the worst character
in the film.
But believe me, I'm good,
I'm a very good person.
(laughter)
In 2016 I was nominate for
Canadian Screen Award as a
best lead actor in a feature film.
I was like thinking of when
you go back 20 years ago,
being nobody and now being nominated,
it's really,
nice feelings.
(piano music)